Hallo hallo BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU!
And today we're your host of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Ruffians!
Are you awake?
Are you ready?
Because today's our 109th episode!
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much for joining us here today on this wonderful FUWAMOCO Morning!
I see some new Ruffians maybe!
Wide awake?
Yeah, you're awake.
Well, maybe this is the first time that you're joining us for FUWAMOCO Morning.
And if it is, well, it's important that you know.
FUWAMOCO Morning is a short 4-nap morning show held every Friday, Wednesday, and Monday.
Aka FUWAMOCO!
Hosted by us, FUWAMOCO!
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help
You start your day off on the right paw.
Yeah!
Please tweet your thoughts with the hashtag, hashtag, FWMCMORNING!
Let's all BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
I don't know, Ruffians.
Today feels like a really special FUWAMOCO Morning.
I don't know why, though.
It's just the 109th.
Do you feel the same way?
Maybe it's because you're here with us this morning!
BAU BAU!
Everyday is special!
It is.
Why are we gonna ruin the special?
Because I... There's been another Pero Sighting.
Let's see where he was.
That way we can avoid it.
That makes sense, right Ruffians?
Yeah.
Oh!
Go out for walks, but...
It's important to do the Ruffian thing.
It's important to go outside.
You have to go outside, okay?
I say so.
You know, to stretch the paws for your physical health, but also, you know, for your mind too.
You have to go outside, okay?
I know.
It makes a big difference for us too, right, Moco-chan?
Even though it's hot outside.
Except when it's hot.
It's still important to go outside, Moco-chan.
Yeah, so Ruffians, let's all make sure that we go outside for walks often, okay?
Just, uh, maybe try not to look at the sky too much if you can.
You get around 10,000 steps a day, good job!
Good, good!
You can do it!
Continue to do your best!
Just don't look at the sky too often, okay?
Yeah, yeah.
Otherwise you may spot Peron!
And that would be no good, okay?
Yeah, that would be pretty nasty.
Yeah.
BAU BAU!
I hope we don't spot Pero.
It would be nice to see, you know, like, anything else.
Yeah!
Yeah.
Moco-chan, we have some exciting news!
Ruffians, we've had so much exciting news to share with you, right?
But this time, it's actually not just our own good news.
Not just FUWAMOCO's good news.
But Icomochi-mama has some good news too!
Icomochi-mama will be holding a solo exhibition of all her books!
BAU BAU!
It's happening very soon, too!
We're so excited!
Congratulations, Icomochi-mama!
Omedetou BAU BAU!
Yeah, we're really excited!
It's gonna be going on pretty soon, from July 26th until August 4th.
And it's gonna be at a place called Ikebukuro Tag.
And there, you know, you can see a lot of MAMA's original illustrations, as well as illustrations of us!
FUWAMOCO!
And other ones mama has done officially for Hatsune Miku as well!
Awesome ones!
FUWAMOFRIENDS!
If you happen to be visiting Tokyo, I'd love it if you could go visit Icomochi-mama's exhibition and give her a big BAU BAU!
Congratulations!
We wanna go check it out too, but I think our ears and tails moistened a little bit.
Yeah.
BAU BAU.
Congratulations Icomochi-mama!
BAU BAU!
Icomochi-mama is amazing, right?
Yeah, so beautiful, right?
Yeah, but you know the ears and tail is a bit hard to hide them, right?
It can't be helped.
BAU BAU!
FUWAMOCO!
Recently we had some fun.
We have fun everyday.
We had some special fun.
We went to a place called Joypolis in Odaiba.
Ruffians, have you heard of Joypolis before?
Wow.
If you have it!
We did talk about it last morning.
Did we talk about it?
Wow!
Joy Police!
It's sort of like if a Sega arcade got married to and then had a child with an amusement party!
We love it so much!
We went in the past before.
But you know, it feels like the best kind of fever dream you can have.
It really does!
Yeah, like it shouldn't exist, but it does!
And you know, we're better off for it.
Yeah, it's really crazy!
But FUWAMOCO, it wasn't just us though.
We went together with Shiori and Nerissa as well!
You know, cause we wanted to go again to Joypolis.
And so we asked Alvin if they happened to be free when we were planning it.
And Shiori and Nerissa were able to go!
And, uh, actually, up until recently, Joypolis was having a collaboration together with hololive, too!
Yeah!
But, you know, now it's kind of ended, and now they're having the Static Beatle collab with Nenechi, too, so it's a bit different, but the fun is still there!
It's still fun!
Yeah, but we were really lucky, so it's amazing timing!
Amazing timing, we're in for it today.
We just really wanted to go to Joyfulish!
Joyfulish is fun!
You know, as a part of the collab, there's many live shows that happen three times throughout the day.
And you know, with our senpai, Kuma-senpai, Watame-senpai, Luna-senpai, Kanata-senpai, Suisei-senpai!
They were really, really cool shows too!
Kind of like, really close up.
Almost like you could touch them, but don't touch!
Don't touch!
Yeah, you know, so I was like,
Oh!
Luna-senpai's there!
Spinning around on stage so fast!
Wataru!
Wataru
FUWAMOCO Morning!
Gekion.
We're still really well, right?
We're a team.
I was a team with Shiori.
Yeah.
How does it look?
So you get in the roller coaster and then there's like a rhythm game to different SEGA games and music.
So you get drivers and then you stop and then you do your rhythm game and you get your score.
And Fuwawa was too scared so it really, really, really bad.
And she's like, when is this gonna be the roller coaster part?
Yeah, you do that a couple times and then it's a rollercoaster!
Yeah, and the rollercoaster goes right over where all our senpai were performing.
Yeah.
And so sometimes there'd just be horrible screams all of a sudden.
Those horrible screams being us two.
Yeah, but I was with Shiori and Nerissa and Fuwawa.
Yeah.
Shiori and I.
We beat them badly.
Yeah, Nerissa gave up playing the rhythm game.
She was too busy singing.
She was singing.
I was like, Nerissa, you singing over there?
She knew all the lyrics.
Yeah.
It was so much fun.
Right?
Yeah.
And we went upside down.
It was difficult.
You went upside down, Moco-chan.
You had your eyes closed, huh?
No, I had my eyes open.
What?
You had your eyes open.
I had my eyes open.
Okay.
Yeah.
It was really fun.
And, yeah, there was also, you know, another game called... It's not a rollercoaster, but it was scary.
Called Halfpipe Tokyo.
And we were in the same team, so me and Nerissa and Moco-chan and Shiori.
And basically, it's like, you have to stand a skateboard.
And it's like a halfpipe.
And then in the middle, there's like a white line.
It's a music game again.
Yeah.
It's a music game.
There's a white line and you have to step.
You have to step with your two feet.
As close as you can, but climb it together.
Yeah.
So you have to work as a team.
And you've gotta aim for the limit break.
Yeah, it's like a standing roller coaster.
Yeah.
But you aim for the white line, which is the limit break, which gets you the most points.
Yeah, and then you- The limit break is like spins!
It spins a lot.
Yeah.
And Shiori and Moco-chan, you're like, okay, we're gonna get over 10,000.
We're gonna get a high score.
If you get the high score of 10,000, then you get something good, and I don't know what that is, so I wanna know what it is.
Right.
And we saw the other employees who are running it, they look at everybody's scores at the end and they laugh.
So we're like, we're not gonna be the ones they're laughing at.
And Nerissa and I were like, okay, like, wait.
Got told how to do it, the instructions are all good.
I think we're pretty good at this.
We're gonna beat Moco-chan and Shiori!
And then as soon as it started, I started screaming.
I was like, no, no, no, no!
No, I'm not gonna beat the new thing!
No, I'm not!
Yeah.
Shiori and I were doing so well, but once we started getting the limit break in a row, it'd be like... And I keep on going faster and spinning more and more.
What was your score in the end, Moco-chan?
I don't even know.
7,000?
No, it wasn't that good.
Nerissa and I had about 4,000.
I think it was like 6,500.
Yeah, they have the scores afterwards, too.
Yeah.
It was really intense, it was fun!
Yeah, we're all sort of dizzy.
Yeah.
And then they had a house of the dead game!
It was really fun because usually house of the dead is like two people only, right?
You just shoot the zombies.
This time it was a bunch of teams, you know?
It was four teams of four.
Yeah.
But so we could battle the zombies together.
All together!
But at the end, they sort of total up the teams and do which team was the best and who was the best player.
Yeah.
Ruffians!
Be proud of me.
I was number one out of everyone in the game.
But!
I was number three for the day.
Third best player of the day.
Wow.
I was pretty good.
I got second at one point.
It was the end of the game.
Yeah, it was the end for the day.
Nerissa almost died.
I didn't get bitten at all.
It wasn't like it was the beginning of the game.
Yeah.
And then, what else did we do?
That's right, there was a place, a thing called Murder Lodge.
And FUWAMOCO didn't go in it, but it's not because we're just big scaredy cats.
It's because the line was long.
They're like, oh, we need two more people.
And then Shiori and Nerissa were like, oh, that's us!
Yeah, they said it was like a spooky ASMR experience.
Yeah, we didn't hear much more than that.
It really was scary.
I think it wasn't as scary because it was all in Japanese, maybe?
Maybe.
Yeah.
And then... Okay, this is the big thing.
We remember this from last time, but there's a thing in Joypolis called Fortune Forest.
Fortune Forest.
And we remember the Fortune Forest.
Fortune Forest is basically like a fortune forest that you go into, you get like a special gem, and then you have to take your gem and it does like a personality test.
Yeah, a personality test.
It shouldn't be that fun.
And it's also like you can do it individually or you can do it as like a couple.
A couple.
Yeah.
Yeah, I can remember it!
It's hard to forget this one.
And you know they have it in English too!
So basically you have to put in your name, and then they ask you, do you want like a fortune based on like your personality?
Yourself?
Or your career?
Romance?
Now talk to us.
It's so interesting.
Aren't those two categories kind of similar?
I don't know.
What do you think FUWAMOCO picked, Ruffians?
Well, it doesn't really matter in the end.
We're not going to read all the fortunes.
No!
But if you go to Fortune Forest, you'll find out they can be pretty wild.
Pretty, pretty wild.
So we had a really, really good laugh at all the fortunes afterwards.
Yeah!
Because they're all in English too.
Yeah, somehow they're very accurate.
I think Shiori's wasn't accurate, is what Shiori was saying.
I feel like it's me-ish.
We read them though, it's sort of ish.
Some of it was weird.
A lot of it was weird.
Okay, so you have your gel and then you have to take it off.
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
We watched many couples go up.
And there was maybe one or two that was a GO AWAY!
FUWAMOCO was also a GO AWAY!
We tried many times, many combinations.
Nerissa Mococo.
FUWAMOCO.
Shiori Nerissa.
Nerissa Fuwawa.
Shiori Fuwawa.
Shiori Mococo.
And we made a lot of people leave.
But we just couldn't get it to win.
And Nerissa was losing her mind!
She was losing it!
FUWAMOCO!
I need to get into this cave!
I can't leave Japan!
I need to go!
Before I go!
I'm definitely not going to get into it!
Because the worst part about it, Ruffians... You can see there's something in there.
You can see, you can see in the cave.
But you can't get in the cave.
It's just blocked off just a little.
Yeah.
So, Ruffians... So Nerissa... She made a search up online.
Wait to be able to get into it.
So we made a- After we went through it, we had a really fun time.
We were like, okay Nerissa's like, I have to go back to FUWAMOCO, so... Yeah!
We kind of searched up online.
At first we tried searching in English.
There's nothing in English.
And then she's like, FUWAMOCO, please find out in Japanese.
So then, we searched it up and we found a walkthrough, guys.
But it's not easy though.
It's not easy, it's based on somebody's drawings.
Which stones you have to pick.
There's a bunch of different stones.
You have to pick them in a certain order.
The certain right ones with the right partner.
Both partners have to get a certain stone.
Yeah, so it's really really really... Cheater!
It's not cheating!
No!
We need to discover the mystery, okay?
No, it's a cat!
She can't leave Japan, okay?
She's like, it's gonna keep me up.
So then, Moco-chan, you and Nerissa, you carefully, carefully chose the stones.
And you're like, okay, I think this is the one we need to get.
Yeah.
And then, you held hands.
And then, it said we could go in.
Yeah.
And I was talking with them.
And we were like, yeah, we can go in!
Yeah, we felt like we were bragging to everyone there.
Yeah, everyone was like, look at us!
We can go in!
Yeah.
And,
I don't want to spoil it, but... It was amazing in there!
You have to do your best, Ruffians, to be able to get into Fenya's cave.
But then afterwards, Nerissa was so happy, she's like, We did it!
We did it!
I can't believe we got into the cave!
Yeah, yeah.
It was worth it.
Definitely, definitely.
But, you know, because of the collab, it was printed on special paper.
Yeah, so we have pretty wild fortunes on paper with our senpai's faces on it.
Yeah!
Yeah, Nerissa was so, so happy!
She was jumping up and down.
Yeah.
Fortune Force is very wild.
It takes, yeah.
You can do it once, or you can do it twice or three times.
We've done it many, many times.
It's so fun.
It's always fun.
Yeah.
Cause you know, you can ask for so many different things, like fortune yourself.
Career.
Romance.
Yeah, Nerissa was like, if I was a kid, this would be the kind of thing that I write stories about.
It's just really fun.
It's really fun, yeah.
Yeah, and then we went on this ride called Wild River.
It was pretty wild.
Yeah.
We tried also the, what's it, the Mystic Mansion?
Yeah, it was like a Japanese themed haunted house kind of 3D, 4D show.
It was pretty cool, but there was one point there was like a fire, a fire ghost.
And we were like, where's the ice ghost?
It got really hot in there, it's so hot!
It was already hot to begin with!
Show us the ice ghost, please!
It never came out, huh?
No.
Yeah.
What else was there?
Oh!
There was... Ruffians, you know Dip n' Dots.
You know the ice cream that's dots.
Dip n' Dots.
FUWAMOCO, we really like Dippin' Dots, right?
Advent, I think we really like Dippin' Dots.
Yeah.
And all our senpai had their own special collab Dippin' Dots!
So, we ordered them all.
We ordered them all.
And we shared them all together!
Yeah, that was like $50.
What?
$50 of Dippin' Dots.
Yeah, and to make it worse, FUWAMOCO didn't have any money.
So does Shiori, but... Shiori, can you lend us money?
Shiori's lent us about... She passed us around thousand yen, ten dollars.
And I'm like, ah, I'm sorry, Shiori, it's gonna be about five times that.
Yeah!
Well, we paid her back, though, right?
Yes.
Right?
I can't remember.
Yeah, and we shared it!
We all fought over Luna Senpai!
That was the yummiest, right?
And we all shared the special goods that came with it.
Yeah, and Nerissa was like, ah, Suisei Senpai's is mine.
For other collab foods check out Moco-chan and I'm Reshed with Tsuruse-senpai's Churro!
It was like a churro that was very blue.
But it's salt caramel flavor.
Oh, salt caramel?
Oh!
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I just tasted the blue flavor.
And then we had Towa-senpai's drink too!
And I think Nerissa got a Canaluna Parfait.
And she let me have the first bite.
Apparently I took too big of a bite.
She's like, whoa Fuwawa!
Did it color your tongue?
I think so.
I think so probably.
Yeah, and then there was like a spin the ball attraction.
Yeah, but like a watery.
Nerissa and I tried it and we both lost.
Yeah, we just got a piece of paper.
Yeah, but a cute piece of paper.
With Watame-senpai on it.
Right.
And there was a big air hockey table for four players!
So we could all play together.
We played air hockey!
They had two different ones, like a traditional air hockey, which is very serious, and then like a free-for-all air hockey where there's a bunch of air hockeys.
Yeah.
We lost both.
But we were very serious about it.
I don't know, I just think that Shiori and Nerissa's teamwork was too good.
BAU BAU Twins.
Moco-chan.
But Nerissa would grab the puck.
And then she would set it up for Shiori.
That's cheating, right?
Typical.
Cheating!
Yo, what else did we do?
That was really fun.
We went to Odaiba.
FUWAMOCO Morning!
Shiori and Fuwawa.
And then Nerissa and I, we went and had takoyaki.
But it was not very good.
That's what you get.
But they had like a rope for us.
And it was kind of in a loop, so at first I was like, I want to be really close to you, Shiori!
Okay!
Don't go for me!
So then I tied the rope around the two of us, so we're kind of like a train.
But then I thought, "that could be dangerous."
So then we undid that.
And we held hands, and I made sure that the rope was going through our hands together.
What?
Yeah, so it was like... It was like this, Moco-chan.
Right?
Yeah.
And I was really scared.
And... We made it through there, but we're holding hands the whole time, and Shiori's like, "it's okay, Fuwawa, let's sing a song."
What are we singing first?
You told me this song, but I can't remember.
I singed "Bad Apple."
Shiori's like, we have to go backwards.
I'm like, no we're not going backwards!
This has to be, this has to be the way!
And yeah, we just weren't opening the door properly.
...
There's so many things to do in Odaiba!
We went to a dagashiya, which is like a place that sells a whole bunch of Japanese sweets!
You know, like little ones!
They'll have like little things of gum that kids could buy with their... Like 50 yen.
Yeah, with okozuka, with their allowance!
So it'd be really cheap!
And, you know, we're like, "Nerissa, Shiori, buy whatever you want!"
But Nerissa's just hungry.
She's like, I want food.
I don't want snacks.
I want food.
Yeah, so she didn't get anything, but that's her fault.
And then Shiori got some stuff.
Yay!
And we paid for it all.
Yeah!
And we also made a bit of a dream of ours come true.
Because we spent over.. 10000 yen, 100 dollars.
We bought so much candy, you know we're adults.
Growing up puppies.
We have a lot of snacks.
And I found a new one that I really like.
It's like dried pickle plums.
They're really yummy.
How heavy was it?
It was heavy.
Yeah.
It was amazing.
Yeah, it was a really big bag.
Yeah, I think the issue was, is that we were shopping separately.
Yeah, Moco-chan and I, so if Moco-chan saw something and she's like, "oh, I'm curious about that."
"I wanna try this."
Yeah, and then I would come by and be like, "oh, I'm curious about this."
Maybe Moco-chan would like one too, so that I put...
And then we ended up buying the same ones over and over.
Yeah.
So instead of two, we'd end up buying four.
That was the problem.
It's just so many!
I wanted to kind of run everywhere and take a look at everything.
I wanted to try them.
Right.
So much stuff I've never tried.
Yeah.
Yeah, we got lots of duplicates.
Yeah, and then I was like, oh, Shiori should try this one, and this one, and this one, and this one, and this one!
Yeah.
So I was just giving her all of the snacks.
The snacks are gonna last forever.
Right?
Yeah.
It was really fun.
We just had so much fun, and you know, we got to read minds together, and just chat about a bunch of things, and be silly, and... No, but soon I will...
I don't know why.
We were like, "oh I'm gonna hit you with my hair!"
"I'm gonna hit you with my hair!"
And then we bonked heads.
That's just how things are.
Yeah.
It's just silly.
It was really, really fun.
We had a good day, right?
Yeah.
That's just how things are.
And that was our fun day at Joypolis!
Did we get any souvenirs?
I got a souvenir actually!
Because it was a really cute crane game.
And it had like an octopus, like a strap, like a keychain in it.
And I really wanted it, but Moco-chan wouldn't give me any money to be able to play it.
So Shiori played it and won me one!
Yeah, so that was my souvenir.
Yeah, it's so cute!
It's very, very cute.
Yeah.
Nice.
It's with us, huh?
Yeah.
He's with all the buddy Noah!
Noah!
We have fun.
Yeah.
And I guess, you know, we have the Fortune Forest Fortunes!
That's another souvenir!
And then all the, you know, the special collab items, too!
And of course, all the memories.
Definitely, Ruffians, you have to go check out Joypolis.
It's just so much fun!
Yeah, and there's a bunch of things we weren't able to do either.
I wanna go again.
BAU BAU!
Yeah, and it's indoors too, so it's nice and air-conditioned.
You can go any kind of weather.
Yeah, it's fun.
It's just so fun.
BAU BAU!
Yeah!
It's so good!
Wow, Ruffians!
This week, you know, we have more FUWAMOCO Mornings coming up, but!
You might have already heard, but FUWAMOCO, we're gonna be going on our first vacation since we debuted!
BAU BAU!
You know, it's just gonna be a few days that we're away for, but
It's gonna be a little bit of an adventure, right?
We're really looking forward to it.
But Ruffians, make sure that we bring back lots of omiyage banashi!
Souvenir stories for you!
But because of that, there's not gonna be a FUWAMOCO Morning, obviously.
But!
We'll be doing a Twitter space, okay?
At the same time.
So we hope that you'll join us there!
And maybe we'll share a bit more adventures so far with you!
Yeah!
And FUWAMOCO will also make sure that we have a live chat here on YouTube open!
And that way, you know, you can chat there, we can chat back with you doing the Twitter space to Ruffians!
Does that sound good?
Will the Twitter space have the Pup Talk?
BAU BAU!
Thank you, Ruffians!
I can't believe we talked this much.
Oh my gosh.
Hi.
Joyful is just out for a drive.
Well, let's check out who our Doggie of the Day is today.
Our Doggie of the Day is... De-den!
Ginger!
BAU BAU!
You're so cuddly.
Why?
How does Ginger BAU BAU?
Just like that, huh?
Well, you know, Ginger here, Ginger has a big nose for kisses!
I'll never ever complain if you know maybe they're a bit too enthusiastic!
I don't think Ginger will complain if you pet him backwards either, right?
You know it.
Yeah, no.
Because, you know why, Ruffians?
Because Ginger is a very well-mannered doggo.
Just make sure that you give him lots of hugs, okay?
I think that might be his purpose in life.
Lots of hugs.
BAU BAU!
Next, "I went for a walk" corner.
"Today I went on a walk" corner.
That's the name.
We have De-den!
De-den!
I love it.
It's so beautiful.
The red, orange, the butterflies.
Nice butterfly.
Actually, FUWAMOCO, I saw a big, big red dragonfly.
I was so surprised.
You never know what you're gonna find on your rocks, right?
Yeah, we've been seeing some big butterflies.
Yeah, just like this, but it was a really, really bright blue, right?
A dragonfly.
Yeah.
Not a dragon.
A dragonfly.
But we still need to see Cicadas!
I haven't seen, I've heard of them.
I keep on looking at the trees.
Where are you?
Get down here!
But not yet.
Not yet.
Yeah.
But I'm really happy that Ruffians that you like to stop and admire these cool bugs and you know the other things that you see on the days when you go for walks too.
It makes me feel even closer so.
Thank you!
Thank you BAU BAU!
And next for our Question of the Day!
We got a question from you, Ruffians!
Let's take a look!
We have de-den!
Hello, FUWAMOCO!
When it's a hot summer day, what is your favorite way to cool down a bit?
Like drinking some cold water?
Maybe getting some ice cream?
Do you have any good friends?
Yeah, the vending machines!
But right now... FUWAMOCO-chan.
I think we talked about it a bit before, but we really like the taxi at the end of the hot and long days.
Yeah.
Taxi.
It's bad, but... Yeah.
It's just so nice being so sleepy and everything is dark, but then there's the lights and it's nice and cool.
Yeah.
It's not good though.
It feels like a dreamer though.
Yeah.
But we're trying to avoid them, right Moco-chan?
But I also made the salty lychee drinks!
And shaved ice too!
Yeah!
And most importantly, 24-7 air conditioning.
Air con!
Yeah.
And the soap tablets too!
Those are important.
I guess it doesn't really cool you down.
Ruffians, make sure you stay cool too, okay?
And don't forget sunscreen, okay?
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much, Ruffians, for all your submissions!
Thank you for always wanting to be a part of
FUWAMOCO Morning here with us.
We're always looking for more questions, more submissions, more Pero Sightings!
Please let us know with the hashtag!
Hashtag FWMCMORNING!
Okay!
BAU BAU!
I see a misunderstanding already.
A misunderstanding?
You don't have to pay an extra fee for the air conditioning.
You're so obvious!
But it's all included, don't you think?
But...
I'm paying for the tires, too.
Yeah.
It's not an extra fee for the tires!
Not an extra fee.
But... I had to wait!
Don't worry!
I saw it coming.
I love you!
BAU BAU!
Ooh, well, we have another stream coming up, Moco-chan!
In a little bit.
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita.
We're super excited.
I can't wait for the songs we're gonna sing together.
This is gonna be really fun.
A lot of us.
So we hope you'll join us, Ruffians.
It'll be on our channel here, and it will be archived.
So that the memories always stay.
And then also, it's important to mention, but that's not our first year anniversary celebration!
We'll be doing that on the 28th on Sunday, and that will also be an old collab!
We're doing some really fun things and maybe have some exciting things too!
So you have to join us there!
BAU BAU!
We also have a Super Mario World endurance as well for our personality!
So, let's have a fun time.
I think we're aiming to make it the longest stream ever for us so far.
We'll see how it goes!
If we beat the game, then it's done.
It's done.
Can't do much more.
BAU BAU!
And for the Ruffians who are joining us to the archive today, here is your FUWAMOCO word!
It's BAU BAU Vacation!
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much, Ruffians, for joining us today for another FUWAMOCO Morning!
Thank you!
Before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Ruffians today!
Nobira!
BAU BAU!
Yakuboyumi!
Zoxwyrs!
BAU BAU!
YZE.
Snow Blain.
BAU BAU!
Georgie.
Jellypaw.
BAU BAU!
Fable.
Poop Teachers.
BAU BAU!
Tiago.
Tiago!
One Marcus.
BAU BAU!
Fuki.
Sid.
BAU BAU!
Add to every other Ruffian out there!
We hope you have a howl of a day!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!